Independence Day is right around the
corner and this year President Trump is
playing in honor America with a very
special fourth of July celebration in
Washington DC complete with military
aircraft flyovers historic tanks and one
of the biggest firework shows in history
but not everyone's excited per usual the
mainstream media is trying to rain on
the parade literally check this out
it's just obscene it really is and I
just I just hope it doesn't spoil the
whole day you see that this is really
problematic to the DC City Council for
several reasons as a native
Washingtonian I find this to be
offensive I don't need a tank in my
front lawn to tell my neighbor
I'm Patriot so what is the message
Donald Trump is trying to send by
rolling tanks down Constitution Avenue
who is that message to it's certainly
not to tyrants because he likes tyrants
he loves tyrants it's not to Putin it's
not to kim jeong-hoon it's not to the
Saudis is it to our friends is it to
Western democracies oh he doesn't
particularly like or is it to us is it
to the resistance in this country it's
always a threat when you roll you out
your military but it's to whom is the
threat and I suspect that the threat is
to his fellow Americans you heard that
right
joy Reid feels threatened by a patriotic
celebration meanwhile out-of-work backup
quarterback Colin Kaepernick is busy
calling the Betsy Ross American flag
racist because it represents the 13
colonies and in the 1700s some colonial
citizens owned slaves according to The
Wall Street Journal the former backup
quarterback turns social justice warrior
called on Nike to remove a patriotic
sneaker featuring the Betsy Ross flag
from the shelves and naturally Nike was
happy to oblige no word if Colin
Kapernick is still triggered joining us
now with reaction on American values on
the result is Fox News correspondent
at-large Geraldo Rivera and the founder
of skybridge Capital Anthony scaramouche
II Anthony that good to see you buddy
it's great to be here with you I'll go
to you first so I thought with
Kaepernick during his infamous NFL
protest he had specifically made the
point that it was not about the flag but
now a flag appears on Nike shoes and
it's about the flag
he's making a strategic bet they what
they want to do is they want to go for
the inner city they want to go for the
youth they want to play the social
justice chord so white affluent sneaker
buyers they've decided not to do that
and that's against the Michael Jordan
adage remember what Michael Jordan said
he said I don't yeah I don't care
they're making a big mistake it would be
a better corporate strategy to be more
inclusive on the military got to talk
two seconds about that on a military I
was actually against it and I want to be
very fair and balanced because I'm often
worried about you know what Eisenhower
said about the military-industrial
complex and then I talked to several
veterans today and I talked to a lot of
people about the Gulf War one parade and
I turned around on it I view it now as I
understand what the president's trying
to do he's trying to celebrate
patriotism he's trying to celebrate the
freedom that the military has presented
and represented for the United States so
I have to confess honestly when I first
heard about it I was less happy about it
but once again the president has way
better instincts than I do about the
American people yes very good as he's
always has or although I'll go to you on
this is this the dumbest business move
in modern American history by Nike are
they just trolling all of us I mean why
make an issue out of this this was a
ground ball it's the American flag it's
not some partisan symbol what's going on
here you know in terms of the Nike and
I'd love to talk about the parade also I
read the whole world loves a parade they
only hate it because Donald Trump
proposed it in Nikes case it just seems
that they're just running so scared
they're afraid to offend anybody they
are so politically correct that they
would unravel a deal that was well
evolved and had really no offense meant
to anybody Betsy Ross my family and I
were in Philadelphia recently you pass
her house the flag that she sewed in
1776 is there out the window people just
relate to it you know it is preposterous
to think that you know you can't honor
our what he wouldn't take down the
Washington Monument next because he had
slaves Thomas Jefferson and so forth in
terms of the parade in Washington I have
to say that
I am really if this is a symbol of the
partisan toxic malignant atmosphere we
have in our country if you see how
Republicans feel about the country right
now according to these surveys as
compared to the way Democrats feel about
this country now according to the
surveys it is amazing people on the Left
hate our president so much that they are
willing to just put a negative spin on
anything how many times have you seen a
flyover in an athletic event yeah you
know everybody loves them except them
until President Trump is the one
proposing it yeah you get goose bumps
with those flyovers and if I was the
great Jimmy Super Bowl and I remember as
a Secret Service agent being at the
World Series when George W Bush threw
out that first pitch I mean there were
no Democrats and Republicans there were
only Americans there at that point well
I mean that's the thing so you've got
the polarity that Geraldo is talking
about and you got a really bad corporate
strategy on Nike they'd be so much
smarter trying to bring everybody in you
know I hate to play devil's advocate but
you know it's it's fair at times some of
the response I've heard from liberals
has been hey Nike stock is up and their
sales are up ever since then you didn't
ask me as a capital manager yeah that's
where we go with this capital manager
when a stock fell off I looked at I said
they're making the right bet they're
gonna sell more sneakers if they do this
but here's the problem you got to be
long-term greedy in a society and a
culture because the pendulum is gonna
swing again dinh and they'd be way
better off trying to be more inclusive
than just focusing on the short termism
of that's right and I agree with you and
Geraldo I'll go - I agree with Anthony
hundred percent I think this was a dumb
long-term move I love this country I
bleed red white and blue always have I
think it's a long term really silly play
but this constant reflection Geraldo by
the left on the negatives of America
focusing on our original sin rather than
the blood we've left on foreign soil and
World War two in World War one freeing
nation's cemeteries we have overseas
with our greatest generation left there
I get it every country has is some form
of original sin many countries in the
world were born out of some violence or
aggression but the United States has
done such wonderful things what is with
this constant harping with the left on
the negative all the time how is this a
winner for them
part of the problem dan and and Anthony
is that we don't have unifying moments
anymore look right now what's happening
you have our women's soccer team in the
World Cup they go into the finals for
the third year in a row under ordinary
circumstances we were right on we'd be
watching in the bars and high-fiving and
back-slapping each other but because
someone asks they can rap a node they
captain to a co-captain of the team
whether she would visit the White House
if they won the World Cup she said no
because she opposes Trump's policy so
out the performance of our national team
in the World Cup something we should all
be extolling their virtue and our kids
should be watching and wanting to play
like they play instead it becomes you
like Trump you don't like Trump you can
visit the White House you're not going
to visit the White House it is you know
it's its melancholy it said objectively
speaking the country is doing great the
economy is expanded for a hundred and
twenty one straight months minority
unemployment is at historic lows the
wealth gap for the first time in many
years
appears to be lessening you know there's
great opportunity the president's trade
deal when he walked into the DMZ and
crossed the line into North Korea
everybody should have been celebrating
you know why if you want to make pieces
Moshe Dayan said you don't speak to your
friends you speak with your enemies the
president went into North Korea the
first president ever everybody should be
celebrating that but because this hatred
of Donald Trump is so intense it he
becomes the synonym for the nation and I
think it's very distressing people
should get over themselves I mean I as a
kid you watch those fourth of July
parades you get a tear in your eye
watching the old veterans the World War
one guy than the World War two guy and
they died off and then you're watching
the Korea well I mean it's a wonderful
life affirming uniting moment and here
we're making it a bunch of crap we're
although Anthony thanks a lot really
beer happy 4th of July
yeah thank you